desalojados por la fuerza el gobierno
francés ordenó el desmantelamiento de un
gran campamento de migrantes en el norte
de la capital parís unas mil personas
procedentes de irak siria y pakistán
estaban acampadas en precarias
condiciones
esta mañana ha llegado la policía han
cortado las tiendas las han quemado y
han metido a la gente en el autobús para
llevarlos no sé a donde
el improvisado campamento era un punto
de partida de los migrantes hacia reino
unido a través del canal de la mancha lo
hacen en embarcaciones inseguras la
semana pasada más de 1000 personas
lograron cruzar a territorio británico
aumentando las tensiones entre londres y
parís
para resolver el problema de las redes
de paso de los campamentos informales de
insalubres y de las muertes durante la
travesía lo que se necesita son días
legales de paso a reino unido no
expulsiones de esta magnitud que sólo
hacen que la gente pierda las pocas
pertenencias que les quedan las
autoridades francesas estarían
ofreciendo a los migrantes la
posibilidad de presentar sus solicitudes
de asilo en su territorio y refugio pero
muchos quieren continuar su camino a
reino unido la ong utopía 56 denuncia
que los migrantes fueron obligados a
subirse a los autobuses estatales sin
conocer su destino
esta es principalmente la política de
acoso e intimidación que es parte de una
política global de no asilo asegurando
que la gente no quiera quedarse y no
haga que otros vengan en el último año
las travesías de migrantes refugiados a
través del canal superan los 23 mil
casos una cifra récord